[Music]
no
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
so
huh
[Music]
let's go
let's go oh that feels so good
let me just make sure of this
easy winning
let's go let's go oh
mate is on the board the maid is on the
board yeah i think she has to go for the
trip
just to go for the tricks she's gonna
move this here but then i just take it
with the this if i move up here is that
checkmate wow
i think that might be and let's watch
him finish this thing yes
23 seconds remaining i got it ah
yeah oh you know what i want to do
i wanted to no
no no no
oh no luckily this game
i haven't so i keep thinking my camera's
over there
this game i haven't i haven't took
royally
so
like last game was fun dude he made me
think
he made my monkey brain have to think
bro
that was i was damn he brought the
monkey brain out of the stone age
watch the commentators be listening in
on this part we are not listening in on
this part
not at all what are you gonna do john i
don't know what are you gonna do what
did i miss what i miss
what i've missed oh we can just take my
[__] rook i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot i'm throwing
i forgot that his rook could attack my
rook
the same way my rook could attack his
i forgot i forgot that his rook
could attack my rook the same way that
he can i'll take it
i'll take it but i no wait a second i
didn't forget that
no he still took my rooks wait no
i'm actually losing my pawn breaks and
what a pawn break is is where you push a
pawn to try to
change the pawn oh
oh my gosh no
oh wow and you you see
[Music]
oh i'm out i'm out guys come on that was
great thanks
he's setting it up yep he's setting up
the ladder checkmate the king only has
one
oh thank god and he
he has it he has it oh my god that was
so
stressful that was so stressful
oh my god i said to my chat i was like
watch this
russia just gonna do all of these moves
and i i said that he did them and he did
them
yeah okay jojo
oh my god
come on come on come on
game oh game on
game on so that's history gig has never
beaten conor until now
conor the heavy favorite to win
tournament arc is now down one nothing
it's win or go home for
i sea believe that i can't believe it
repeats with the knight c5 with the draw
oh
i don't know if he knows three move
repetition if black plays king c7 it's a
draw
oh no don't play king c7 please
oh by repetition
what can we see but
wow it's really
oh my god what how is that a drool by
repetition
oh my god
and we are here jt what is it like
watching that footage from last year is
it does it bring back
all the things that get us ready for
today's match
it's nostalgic for sure oh man ah
i just i i love the uh the rustage clip
he can
uh that always makes me laugh and it's
it's a great it's a great clip
that's what we have today in the first
match right yeah rustage is back
and uh somebody in the chat just said
that rustage
has like a whole council of people in
his head
while he plays chess and uh i think
that's a good way to describe wrestig
but he's
i i think as a council they're pretty
strong because rustic
played awesome chess in the first season
and i
i i think he's gonna do great before we
get into all of this
let's explain how this event works
because like people
may not know maybe tonight for it could
have been the first uh night that they
tuned in if so you missed
an amazing first day but it's okay
you're here we're here we're gonna
explain how this works
turn on arc 2 is a double elimination
event and what that means is even the
people that lose
in today's match the people that lost in
yesterday's match
they're still going to have at least one
more match to stay in it
the people that win in this first round
are going to go to a winner's side
people that lose are going to go to a
redemption arc
where they will be able to make their
way one of them all the way back
to win the whole thing uh there is a 10
prize pool which is double what we had
last year
and the first place winner of tournament
arc 2
is gonna get four grand second place
third place 1500 fourth place 800 and
then fifth through eight
will each receive 300 bucks which is
awesome everybody gets a little
something
the time control for these games is
going to be 10 minutes
with a 5 second increment and that means
that every move you make
you get 5 minute five seconds five
minutes that'd be
awesome right five seconds added to your
clock
uh and if they're tied for whatever
reason after these three games
uh with 1.5 uh points a piece
will go into a tiebreaker we saw that
yesterday in the first pairing between
crazy ollie and kizzy k
where they played three minutes with
zero increment on the clock it was
wild and uh yeah so
jt before we get all of that started
let's maybe show people
real quick what that looks like what
does a double elimination bracket look
like well
you can see right here in blue that's
the winner's side so
anyone who wins their round one game is
going
up anyone who loses is going down into
the red portion at the bottom which is
the redemption arc
we already see that uh crazy ollie has
won her match
so she is in the winner's bracket e sam
defeated sagam yesterday two to zero
uh now also in the winner's bracket and
uh
kizzy and sajam have moved down into the
redemption arc where they cannot lose
another match or they are knocked out of
the tournament
all four of those participants are now
waiting to see
what happens today with our two
match-ups tech tone b
russige sea dog va versus giger
in order to find out who their opponents
will be
which will then carry on to tomorrow and
thursday next week um
so before we get into games we have
something important that we need to take
care of and that's who is going to play
as white
in the first game in our first matchup
between rustige and tektone and we got a
little
digital coin here we're going to flip
this tech tones
on the other side of this and we're
going to see uh who gets to play white
in the first game
here we go
okay techtone is gonna be playing with
the white pieces in game one
all right jt before we go to break real
quick how do you feel about this matchup
i think that they're both extremely
nervous here
i got to talk to both of the competitors
and
nerves are going to be a big factor
i want to remind them hopefully they're
listening to the broadcast
for now to just take your time
make solid moves and remember we're only
expecting your best
and that's it we're not expecting you to
play like magnus carlsen carlton maxwell
can you play like on tomorrow
um or we're just expecting you to do you
and play your best so good luck to both
of you guys yep
uh and with that said we are going to
take our first break and when we come
back
game one of the round one matchup
between
techtone and rustic see you guys in just
a second uh and with that said
we are going to take our first break and
when we come back game one
of the round one matchup between
techtone and russet
see you guys in just a second
hey how are you seeing me
wait what the [__] wait [__] uh
wait oh jesus christ
that's awkward uh um
that's real awkward uh hey
hey nice to meet y'all just get out
doing my face congratulations just
started doing my
thing didn't uh know didn't know i was
expecting company
hey it's a pleasure to have
you here at uh twitch.tv for slash tech
don't look
real good looking real good members of
chat you know
we over here we like to keep things just
a little bit classy a little bit sexy
a little bit intense and today hustle
loyalty respect are the three mottos i
live
by my game rustage
i'm gonna still i'm gonna take my time
we're gonna enjoy
this time to shine here and uh win or
lose
that's all right that's okay i still got
five cats that love me you know what you
know while i got you here let me show
you my little boy
oh look at this one yeah
look at this one this guy's name is fish
he's a good boy all right cool
time for some peace quiet and some
tranquility
you got this tacky eggy love thank you
once we're gonna be going emote only
mode and alerts off
uh before my match starts so hopefully
this will go good
and i got white dude pogba's coin flip
you'd love to hear that
getting white first that's kind of big
oh [__] i'm getting my nervous spits so
where the [__] am i nervous
i don't think i'm nervous am i nervous
because i've only played chess for like
a week
am i nervous because if i lose
chad's just gonna say can't will your
way out of this one again
who knows but if you would like to
before the rounds start if we would like
to take this hype train home and uh
welcome all of the new hundreds if not
thousands of followers that we're
getting at every mere
moment of our awaiting
for the finale because let's be real
dude
me versus rustage it's pretty much the
main goddamn event of wrestlemania
okay everybody's already me out
they say techie you've only played for a
week
you can't possibly win this
but me i'm standing up for the little
guys
i'm standing up for the people who say i
could never make it
i'm standing up for the people who won't
believe in themself because i am you
it's never too late to succeed it's
never too late to make a change
it's never too late to start something
new
it's never too late to become the you
that you want to be
phantom red wing here with the five
gifted subs you beautiful man
ho ho ho hunty give me the gifted seven
if you excuse me
should i pop an anti-stress bell can you
go back into live chess plays of course
for you
i'm there congratulations
peggy starr bro thank you chad for all
the uh generosity i appreciate this
i am going to put on some animal
crossing music though abel sisters
extended i am getting the music to keep
me calm
wow dude do you think that he put the
jacket on because this is like his
entryway into politics because that's
speech
i i would vote for him
yeah techy for president that was that
was inspiring i
i'm more pumped now than i was before
for this match and uh it's gonna get
started any second like
i i you know of all the things right
there's so much history here with
tournament archer one with rustage and
and
but obviously uh with sea dog and
giga getting a rematch of their their
final
uh pairing um after this pairing like i
kind of like
i i'm i'm almost a bit
i'm more stoked for this like this is
crazy it is happening we're underway
it's going
look at this right and uh russia moving
on a lot of
pawns in the opening d5
what is happening restage what's going
on what is the council saying we let's
just listen now
yeah [__]
okay
how to recover from this
it's not good to feel like you already
have to recover on move three i'm just
gonna i'm
just gonna set up right right this it
could be okay it could be okay
i think it's okay
it's fine i can't believe i did that i
can't believe i moved the wrong pawn
i can't believe i moved the wrong pawn i
had i had i knew what his opening
strategy was going to be and i had a
technique to counter it and i moved the
wrong pawn
um
now the question is can i recover from
this if i move this pawn up
he's going to definitely attack it but
my plan is to
send he hasn't castled yet so i'm gonna
do this
i like how he points out that his
opponent hasn't castled
but then doesn't castle himself okay now
he does good good good
he just got so yeah he's like wow he
hasn't castled so
i'm also not gonna castle hmm strategy
okay i don't particularly like the
castle there
just because the the uh the bishop and
cleaner have this battery but
you know maybe maybe if we just put it
clicking here we'll be okay
right it's it should be all fine um the
computer says one thing but they have to
find the best moves right so
um let's see yeah and it seems like uh
rossignol studying what techie has been
doing so i i just want to see what
techie's feeling
and how he yeah yeah is this the
structure that you taught tech tone
about
yeah yeah yeah this is exactly it okay
he's doing it
what was the strat all about you like
brought everything to the middle
uh no free piece that blocks no free
piece that blocks
uh you move that forward
i don't think i want to fight you
[Music]
i don't think that's something that i
want
so i would like you to not hit me
i don't i don't want that
[Music]
okay he moves that
forward now what is the risk of me say
taking this
with horse he takes it back with bishop
and then that's pretty much the end of
it i think taking this with horses right
and then afterwards i can just take with
uh
i can take here as well then i stack my
pawns and i think that's fine too
wow i'm actually really impressed with
techtone's reasoning there
birds two people who said that they're
nervous before
this game i mean they are playing some
uh
some good chess uh rustage seem
seems to have a game plan ready for uh
sextone
so what else it is we have
we have i think some animation from
russell yeah
he's excited about that because i [__]
i knew i would [__] it up
i can move this up here and threaten
that which
was probably my best move uh
sorry moves the uh the knight back
[Music]
i wonder if the the commentators are
going to be like
he was probably going to go for that but
it [__] up okay now i think i can do
my technique
let's see if this works out for me look
at russage
the boys have uh yeah he had some
tactics he was able to win the pawn
on on h3 and jackie's saying him now i'm
going to attack you
the thing is and russet was not
expecting that
but you got a pawn it's fine that is
interesting oh it's because he's already
pushed
because he pushed the pawn that is
interesting
now why has he done what do i do against
i didn't think about that
i guess if i move this pawn up uh
if i push this pawn up i got a strong i
could check him actually
and he has to move it back but then he's
just going to take and i won't be able
to take anything back um
and i can't take here because he's got
the pawn here
so i'm just gonna do that okay because
it still kind of defends on the diagonal
still
uh i like it i i like i like hearing
both of them talk their way through the
dilemma
and then only weighing a couple choices
right not giving themselves decision
paralysis of like i'm gonna
there's so many things they just kind of
focus on what's important and then they
then make a decision and go it's it's
great
honestly really smart um
there's uh an attack that black has
especially like with this pawn here and
getting the pawn
to be pushed over here to um
to h4 seems a little bit scary and kind
of going for the set play but he's
getting attacked here
i wonder if russiag is going to find a
way to break through or
is going to keep thinking about what he
needs to do
um if we see the time here
cone is up a whole minute so far and
this is the opening stage
yeah and he's being because he's gonna
translate to something yeah
yeah it's almost like you know what th
this
oh okay h4
let's go rustage is working it
let's see if techtone realizes
how important it is to address this and
then take it with my horse
let's see i think i kind of like because
then i come out a pawn ahead
you might be missing that after the h
pawn moves the rook actually
is staring down the king yeah
[Music]
okay i think that was a waste of a move
i think i showed a horse there last time
but i'm still prepping to have the
rocket propulsion battery system
[Music]
i mean he's he's super boxed in there
right like he's super boxed
did he say rocket propulsor system okay
so he took there that's a technical term
which means now i just take with pawn no
i think i just take with pawn
[Music]
okay
and then from here i have take horse
so maybe we'll go to defend it and if he
goes to defend it i'll just take that
with horse
and then he takes back and then i take
back again and then he goes that's the
queen line but he can't move the queen
because i think with the king
[Music]
have a little wusa
yeah and i like how he's doing it on his
opponent's time
he's not using his time
and yeah he put on the uh the jacket to
take off the jacket
this is the tech that we were talking
about
let's see how rustic is working the same
problem
that's not good
um let's go with the tropical shirts i
like it
that's a bad position for me to be in
oh i'm taking too much time taking too
much time i might have to make the move
anyway and just hope he doesn't
think about that can't play hope chess
yeah hope chess is one of the worst kind
of chess
takes he takes [__] me
uh this is why i can't play chess when i
only had like 20 hours
i haven't had 20 i'm gonna wait for like
20 hours
this is under threat anyway
gotta do something
what am i doing
this is a right now it's a strong
position as long as i have the rook
defending it
this is a pinned pawn actually
i should have thought of that beforehand
i can move the rook up because it's a
pinned pawn but there's no reason for me
to do so at the moment
is this a blunder no one will know
if he takes i take
this is looking kind of dicey
i want to see what's happening here and
he sees that he can take back with the
queen as well which i think is an
important thing to notice
because the queen is supported by that
rook
yeah and tucky has to kind of uh be
careful because of this
this whole line here so you can't really
you can't really take
and this bishop is kind of misplaced
um this queen although if when the
center is all closed
this queen is good to to here and have
this kind of setup
but they're attacking on the king's
episode we need some more pieces on the
king side
yeah your king needs more helpers right
now
and techie is definitely spending his
time right now because he knows this is
critical
we've reached a place where every
decision is going to have
serious ramifications i have time i
should use it if i go there
then he takes there and i can take
and then he takes okay
i go here he takes
i go there
[Music]
[__] i need to get rid of this pawn
i rocket boost right here right now what
does that do for me
not really anything what is the rocket
boost i need
interview question i think i might just
need to cut my losses
i actually don't know what to do for
that at all oh dear god
oh god he has so much offense over here
bro
[Music]
do i use this to get my king away
i'm gonna just bring my queen into
battle dude i'm gonna have to be
ready for whatever comes next yeah not a
bad decision
i mean you gotta work a tough situation
here
so i understand it and now they're
almost even on time again
i'm just looking at this position it's
just
the defenses kind of got shattered i was
like oh no
uh and there is a checkmate looming if
the king takes you know there
there might be some ideas of this or
maybe even just night here
and saying you can't really move but
let's see what uh what they have in
store let's see what russia has in store
for us
now the question is where do i go from
here
i don't want to block off my queen's
attack but i could
move my queen here and try and go for
this
i'm going to try that if i move my queen
here
try and go for that he will um he can't
really move anywhere he could only stop
it by
moving the uh that
i must still try it
okay i don't have enough time to like
think of all the consequences of my
actions
um yeah if he moves this which is i
think the obvious
move um i might have to
go for a different approach
that's interesting that is interesting
that means that if i do do this and put
him in check
he uh can still move here
but alternatively i could put him in
check here but i can't take his
thing because he'll just take
i can uh put him in double check if i
move my
horse here he's checked here and he's
checked there mmm
which might be good he would have to
move here spicy
and then i think what is missing is that
queen h
two is check made in one
in his other analysis of where the king
could escape to he didn't notice that
his pawn on e4 actually covers the f3
square
right
oh he and he went for the double check
here
he and i think there might be some
relief and
textiles just saying i see your moves
i'm running
i'm out yeah and i mean now he could
play queen
h2 check but
tech tone could block with the rook
block with the queen create
an exchange on that square and escape
and this is
very surprising because we might have a
tactic come up
in this position if just rook takes
then we have night takes after and
that's
it looks kind of bad because yeah
they're going to get the queen yeah
oh it just goes for the smaller one okay
our king
just needs to run over i am
running and with with the time
difference
right with the time difference it's like
okay
you have to make me you have to come for
me i don't have to come for you
yeah make all the right moves and tech
tone seems to be
dealing with this more calmly than i
expected
and he's realizing that he has time to
work it out as well i have to move back
one more time
[Music]
what does that get you i'm actually not
sure
[Music]
so he's cut my army in half
which sucks he's still ahead by two
this [__] right here really [__] me up
[Music]
you can't take anything yet so
i mean that's good i think next thing i
need to do is i need to like jet
boost this up that way i can get my
bishop
a little bit more online i hope okay so
he took my pawn that's chill bro that's
totally fine
uh i could go trade
[Music]
yeah that's that's awesome
but um we just have to hope that he
doesn't see
this uh this check and that wins the uh
that's a
it's a check on the king and the queen
it's a fork we just have to hope that uh
let's
see if you're rooting for us if you're
rooting for uh saxon
but otherwise a solid move but does that
feel okay like let's say
you know you just move back to d1 and
you can still trade off on e1 and
yeah you're down a little bit more
material but like you've kind of
stalled the attack but maybe not there's
two rooks i mean rusted just really like
just
owning this side of the board
right right i mean but russet only has a
minute
and 20 seconds left right so
it's getting kind of tough for him he
has to find all the right moves
and maybe seeing the knight check
because yeah that's pretty typical
you know what's kind of crazy
yeah i mean what's kind of cool about c4
as well is maybe it's
got rustage thinking that there's
something else going on he's not paying
attention to
that's gonna distract him from his own
attack
right he did take two minutes on one
move
i mean i'm in the lead but i'm taking
too much time
this is bad because he just takes see i
thought it would be good but it's like
actually bad turns out there's a time
warning
i can't believe i'm doing this [__]
i gotta make faster moves even if
they're gonna be bad
i don't have the luxury to take my time
anymore
i think i can do this now there we go
cause he's still simplifying things
right he found it he found it he's gonna
beat me on time though
yeah i think he has to play faster queen
taken i should have done that before i
didn't see it before
queen taken that's good um
you have to do a now what and you gotta
do it quickly
okay i like that no i should have got
this [__] guy out of the way
very nice out of the uh out of the pin
this is where i just sack something to
get some space and some activity
and i think we found a tactic here with
a knight e4 little fork here
and also this is still being threatened
so yes uh
find some answers and with 15 seconds on
the clock
these answers are going to be very hard
to find quickly
okay so knight takes queen takes and
yeah it's hard to break through here the
king is actually
in a spot where you have to remaneuver
to get at it again
yeah let's see what tech he's saying and
thinking about this position
[Music]
and then he takes the then he takes that
and then i take
uh nothing hold on i think i actually
move back maybe i move back one square
[Music]
okay comfortable four minutes on the
clock
[Music]
okay so then he's gonna jet boost what
if i take this here
uh oh is that actually checkmate is that
actually a dead ass checklist
it is can't go there couldn't i go there
what can i go there oh it is [__]
actually he had me with like 50 pieces
like
dead ass check i didn't i thought he was
just going to be able to move out of
that
i don't i took forever this [__] guy
in chat listen this guy
this guy i don't know who the [__]
oh my gosh that's amazing yo rustage
figured it out with 20 seconds left on
the clock
wow that was awesome
what a first game
it was it was interesting it was very
very
there were a lot of moves there that
weren't found in the attack
it was like an attack defense attack
defense and then white was better black
was better and it was kind of the same
thing that we had in the previous games
um especially in the first round with uh
crazy ali and um
izzy and wow what a checkmate he didn't
even
to check me he found it though he found
the best move
i mean you know sometimes you just you
find a good check and his checkmate and
there it is
rustic took the first game now we go on
to game two where we switch colors
rustage will now start with the white
pieces and
uh techtone's got to stay in it i think
he's got the patience to do so
and uh we're about to find out so we'll
be back back
in just a moment with uh game two
next game coming up soon okay jesus [__]
me all right i just gotta draw this game
but i might
lose it and then if we go to blitz i've
lost
if we go to
blitz i've lost because this is what
happened with the anime man i won one
game he won one game
um and we went to blitz and um i lost
because i as you can tell i just
overthink and can't think things through
correctly i try
to i don't want to blunder so um
i should do more what i should do more
thinking on the opponent's turns
instead of berating myself on the
opponent's turns
short break three minutes or so did
something happen
okay i got a short break should i get my
water i might get more water then
there's a short break i'll get more
water
he made some really good moves i wasn't
expecting
that move ignoring my pawn this move
where he moved the king instead of
taking with the bishop i didn't expect
that
and i don't know why i didn't i think
it's because
whenever i've tried to like go through
this analysis he hadn't moved this pawn
up yet
his pawn was like this in my like
goldfish version of the game
and so he couldn't actually do that
am i allowed to do an analysis i assume
i'm not allowed to do like an actual
analysis on the game
right now in this short break so i'm not
going to
i'm not going to but then oh my god if
if techie ends up doing it
uh i don't think he will let me get some
water gamers
apparently it's a short break i need
this water to survive
[Applause]
oh my water bottle my water bottle fell
over again
my [__] hearts jesus christ
you
i think maybe thank god for the
increments because
when i normally play 10 minutes there's
no increments
um
to make sure to let me win the next one
so it's more intense
he just he just said to me tequila said
that's so funny
i'm glad to hear that uh rustage
is reminding himself that there is
increment right
i think that's really important to
remember
especially going into this next game
after struggling with time on game one
and
and yes he got the victory but
it could have gone either way this could
have been a game about time
yeah i mean there was 20 seconds to four
minutes
and sometimes when you're thinking about
trying to find the best move or
checkmate
you just get lost in the sauce and it
runs out and it happened to me on
countless occasions i'm like wait
did i have more time and it's
unfortunate but uh what is techie doing
right now
what is that face me do
this to just embarrass everyone
and [__] everything up just just don't
let people
get what they want
[Music]
psychic yourself
come on bro come on bro
no way we lose two in a row
well i mean there's only one way to find
out techie we're gonna start the second
game right
and we're gonna see bro here we go
rustage with the white pieces
okay so this looks like they're both in
preparation they know their sequences
here
he's doing his thing he's doing his
thing looking good
this is basically set play this is what
exactly
what he needs to be doing you know um we
just
get our pieces all to good places the
hippo
um and especially like make sure that
they don't get that battery that bishop
and
um queen battery on h6
and here you never take and you're
always able to push let's see if he
remembers that
you know what i find interesting is the
three minutes the three pawns in the
center
every time with both openings rushes
like sad thing
that thing the people play
that is a thing um this is almost
looking like a very normal position
um and i just really want h6 because
bishop h6
leads into some some nasty characters i
just kind of want h6 to be played
that way the h6 squared is covered and
we're not trading off any
pieces unnecessarily okay well
h4 i wonder
if and does h4 being played by white
like make you want that h6 move
that you just talked about like is that
yeah is that really important now more
so than before
yeah because if they try to play it here
then we we can just kind of like stop
them in their tracks we haven't
committed
this king anywhere yet
the king can stay in the center it's
fine in the center and
with hxg5 maybe f5 becomes a very
very powerful idea so let's see let's
see
let's see what i i would want to see h6
here but i
i'm kind of glad that techy's taking his
time here because
he was above increment he had like 10 24
or 10 20 in
i'm glad you're taking his time here
like okay what's the idea
yeah h4 let's start to think okay
uh this is odd
[Music]
uh if i go there but if i go here he
can't take anything
[Music]
maybe i block him right here
cuz then he can take with me he can take
with his bishop
but i think i would like that trade and
then i can just reblock his position
with my pawn
and then i feel like that'd be good for
me i'm gonna try it and if i lose
because of this smudge
[Music]
but i don't want to lose out of fear
that is a great great way to take this
game you do not want to lose out of fear
[Music]
do
come on rusty this music is making me
have like early covet flashbacks
of playing animal crossing like 20 hours
a day for like
months
oh man those are the days and he castles
instead of playing h6
so the idea was supposed to be
that instead of castling we just bring
our king
over and we castle by hand so we play
h6 and then we castle by hamburg
bringing the king all the way over and
i'll just draw arrows basically like
this
and then finally move the rook so that
we always have cover for
the uh h6 pawn wow
so your point got proven there i think
that h6 really was necessary and wait
oh wait there
is a free bishop on the board this
bishop is now free
he needs to take it immediately
this bishop is now free and russia just
screaming
i'm still going to do it
[__]
ah the whole point was the queen
protected the bishop
i now unprotected that by moving the
[__] knight i had two different
techniques trying to go on at the same
time and i blundered myself
i was so confident now if he takes the
bishop
i'm [__] i'm not completely [__]
but i can't move this because now he's
pinned the knight against my queen
i could still do that and then it's a
queen trade
whoa actually if i do that it is a queen
which is bad
is it okay if i do this i can't even do
that because he's got a [__]
pawn there what was i thinking what was
i thinking
all right i blended i blunted i blunted
i had a good i had a good move i
shouldn't be getting this [__] angry
at myself for blundering this badly
[__] okay i can't do this i can't
oh my god the council has convened
oh man i just love the way he goes
through everything and he's like yes
no yes no yes yes yes wait no
it's totally lost except it isn't but it
is but it's not
yet but it will be or will it
but then he has this move well wait i
plan for this move what my
strategy let's see how techtone is
calculating this because i want to see
this situation on the other side yes but
i have to say that i feel like that is
chess condensed in like a three second
clip right there
yeah calculation personified
and now if you move your horse i'm gonna
kill your queen
[Music]
okay i mean so now let's think
so he moved this pawn up in order to
attempt for me to force that but if i go
up and i think i just move up here no is
anybody goes there i'd take if he goes
there
he goes there i take if he's up here
and he's gonna fork me again which i
really don't want
so then how do i prevent this
i feel like i actually cannot move this
pawn i feel like i need to have this
pawn here
uh so maybe i actually move with my
horse instead maybe if there's something
dope i could do with this horse
i can't go there i can't go there i'm
actually kind of blocked in
[Music]
and now techie's the one low on time
hey spending a lot of time for this i
kind of have sixes
quite a good move i i really hope he
finds it and
i think black would be just winning here
but
it's up to zaki to find out
to find this move and maybe we have some
pins going on
and it doesn't matter where the knight
moves because we always have
this move and with bishop captures d2
it's a check
it's a check and checks always come
first
that's weird right because you're not
really dealing with the
with the situation that's right in front
of you
right right it's almost like in the
other game
the the pawn move on the other side you
know the situation kind of helped techy
but now
like it's
not addressing what what the real
problem is and maybe
rustage gets out of trouble here with
this trade
i mean i i still think um well techie's
still up a piece right
he still has a piece oh man this can get
very very dangerous and there's a free
queen on the board okay
no no no no no i didn't mean to click no
no no no no no no no no i didn't mean to
click i didn't mean to click no no no no
no no
no no no no i didn't mean to click i
didn't mean to click that was a miss
click
that was 100 a missed click misclick
that was 100 a missed click
no okay that was 100 percent of missing
that was just a miss click
that's so tragic uh what say you know
it is tragic oh man
yikes
that is tragic that's harsh
and that's chess that's what happens you
play online chess and
you think you're clicking with the right
clicker and you click with the left
clicker and
oh man the amount of time that that this
has happened to me
online it's astonishing but it's oh my
i i feel russ is just paying i i know
i've been there many many many times
yeah i do too but i will say
that rustage did win a game right so the
match is
1-0 rustage can afford
to lose the second game it's it's not
over till it's over right
right and
it's up to teki to win this right like
he has to convert
yeah and let's see what he intends to do
from this point
[Music]
um
okay a masterful play
uh i can
i can take that and be happy i can take
that be happy i can
go here and nothing can kill me there
and i love the sounds of that or i can
also just go right here in front of this
pawn
i think i'm down to do i don't think i
want to try it here
i'm down just don't blunder your queen
that's all you got to do not blunder
your queen
and we're gonna be a happy boy here
[Music]
okay so you moved that piece in
okay rusty's doing a decent job of
saying like i'm not gonna let this be
easy for you
right right and if that's tenacity that
really defines
players you know you always have to be
tenacious even if you're losing
you always have to find the best moves
just remember that 40 good moves
get counteracted by one bad move so you
always want to
keep playing and keep fighting don't
give up even if you're losing you have
to try to find active plans and ideas
yeah and with this move queen captures
g2 now we're attacking this night
and we also have some very nice escape
squares as well with checks
so i wonder what's going to happen here
um i wonder what russet is thinking
about this position because
he's still up two minutes but
i wonder what he's calculating yeah he's
definitely working the problem
and i also want to say that you know for
me
my favorite wins are comebacks from
a worse position and uh you know
i'm about the same level as these guys i
would say it's always possible
it is always possible you can create
some kind of tricky uncomfortable
situation
that turns the tide but the fact that i
just
i got this play i guess threaten that
but it doesn't really do anything let me
think
let me think he can't take this because
of this but what he's going to try and
do
he's going to try and move the piste
he's gonna he's going to go on the
attack now he could
i think his best move is to move this
down here i'll take that
that's good too no i can't move here in
here
i could threaten the queen
he's working the problem and having the
memory of a goldfish
right 10 seconds something happens you
feel some kind of way and then 10
seconds later
hey where am i what's going on oh this
is a chess game okay cool let's fight
i
would like to see some more pieces into
the game into the action right
this bishop is pretty bad right now and
he's getting it active right
there might be some ideas here to get it
active or maybe you know getting into g4
um oh conversely
i would love to see a rook
oh sorry i was seeing old hybrid i'm
seeing an old highlight thinking
techtone was giving the queen back sorry
sorry sorry
and um you know i would love to see like
queen check and then moving the rook
over just
trying to get all the pieces active oh
yes perfect
um you know and
i just want to see all of his pieces
getting active and
doing something instead of just being
stationed like this this rook is fine
it's kind of protecting the king
but all the pieces should be the attack
yeah and let's say even a move like
c6 is going to be really really powerful
at some point oh yeah
let's check in with uh let's check in
with them and
see what uh they have to say yeah i was
gonna say we could also check in on the
time too i mean
tech tone three and a half minutes to
rest to just five and a half
i think i'm free to take this pawn next
if he moves then i can take this and
then he doesn't have the defenses ready
so i can take that and then i can take
his horse
okay so we move that there so now i
think i do take this 100.
i take the pawn he can't take anymore
and if he does i take back
and then also if he takes then i also
get the check again although maybe i
could have gone backwards but if i go
backwards then it would have given him
my queen i really don't want to blow my
queen right now nor ever
[Music]
okay this is how we feeling dude
i like that realizes that he's low on
time and playing a bit faster
hmm okay
russet's continuing to kind of say like
i just don't want you in my neighborhood
right now
with that move right and
but what about
yeah yeah do you see it
i was thinking something simple like
knight takes on c3 check you let the
pawn take it
bursts everything open it just makes it
easier the
the bishop can take the pawn in the
center now that the knight's no longer
defending it and there's just
natural development from there that
leads to checkmate right
yeah that seems that seems like a great
idea actually so
that's a move that that i was thinking
about myself you know
just uh night knight takes
on a c3 and
there's two moves here there's either
the pawn takes or king up
uh oh
what is happening here he just said i i
don't want to lose a queen so
i'm moving all the way back yeah but you
know i don't hate
right because maybe you get your rook
behind your queen get the bishop out of
there and then just
in your face checkmate on b2
let's see if russia should have to be
very careful and russell's
extremely careful yeah
and russ has just highlighted that on
the board he does see that there's
cause for concern there this actually
doesn't look too bad of a move
um
if i can get that then i can then i can
get that up counter attack
check him here if he moves here
i i win if he moves there do i win
is this a win is this a win maybe
letting go of that
without realizing it it's protected uh
he can't move there because of the night
it's not it's not why is this not
checkmate
i forget that he could just take the
night that was actually a blunder in my
pot
that was just a blunder in my part i
should have moved this first
i can still check him there
then you just move here
i can't take time
yeah this is hard to work here very hard
to work for russiage
jt doing a little bit of lip sync action
right now
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i i was just like how can he
do this
what's happening here but i was just
thinking that the rook would come over
first before the rook take so that
you're actually threatening checkmate
that was you know if secton missed that
then that would have been checkmate
in gg in game over okay but now you got
to think about the clock right
i look at the clock and i go okay
techtone
has like two minutes plus some extra
increment moves
like to checkmate me right so maybe
i back off a little bit slow it down
defend my king
like and then kind of like we saw in the
other match with esam and sajam
yesterday
just like yeah i'm gonna make you figure
it out
and this is a good move too because if i
uh
you know prior to this moment take the
knight the pawn is pinned and can't
recapture so
russia's thinking tactically here
this could potentially be a problem i
actually want to see what
russell just thinking about here because
this could be a problem for techie
is that a good thing to do probably
i get a pawn by putting him in check
he's just gonna move hero here yeah
there
i can't do that because of that but i
guess if i take then i can do that
it becomes a trade but now i can do oh
wow oh wow
russet has a check made into yes
we're going to leave the audio open but
come to the live board
because he may seal the match right here
will he spend the two minutes he has
working this out
i don't have time to think about this
you do you have two whole minutes i'm so
down on material but i'm still trying to
check in with my two rooks and that's it
my fingers
oh [__] me wait did i
just lose no [__] way
that's crazy he actually got me
i haven't no that's me for sure i'm
gonna move down then if he moves out
i'm gonna move up and then if he moves
down i'm gonna move down and i'm gonna
try and get him on a stalemate what
i don't know if he knows about stanley
by repetition but i think i'm just going
to go up and down he might think it's
even funny he might be like ha ha
no more people than just techie will
find that funny if you play that no you
can't
is this oh yeah hold on let me think if
i put my rook here
he can't move here here here here he
can't move there because my pawn
weirdly he can't move there
oh my god how did i check how did i win
that game how did i win that game
i misclicked my queen and i still won
how did i win how did i win listen hear
me out
hear me out what the [__] is happening
[Laughter]
what's happening is you just won your
match dude
you won
wow what a comeback literally what a
comeback
blundered a queen blundered a knight
and then was like you know what i don't
need these pieces let me just get in
there
wow this is tournament arc at its finest
man
both of the first matches yesterday and
today have been like
just the epic chess that you hope you
will get
from this tournament man oh my god this
is fantastic
so wow rustage pulls
what i i don't think i've seen a bigger
emotional rollercoaster in chess in my
entire life
that was oh my gosh that was fantastic
well there's how is there so much hype
in the beginning rounds
like i i don't understand literally in
the beginning rounds of
both days we just have hype after hype
after hype moment oh my what a roller
coaster
you know what we're gonna have to do
we're gonna have to say hi to gigguk
right now and tell him that he has to
top that somehow
so do it with me everybody hi gigguk
hi we'll be right back everybody stay
tuned
rostage went through such a like roller
coaster of emotions during that
how was there so much hype in the
beginning rounds like i i don't
understand literally in the beginning
not as strong as the audi armor
yeah yeah i got it i got it it wasn't as
strong as the aliyama
like holy [__] that stalemate in the
third game
right now and tell him that he has to
top that somehow
oh great do with me everybody hi gigguk
hey aaron
hi hey be right back everybody stay
tuned
okay great now i'm live now i'm live
okay well i guess i gotta prepare for my
match against connor
now um
let me stop this before it goes
into a echo
um yeah i guess i got to prepare for my
match against connor
if you want to see the long long-awaited
monk versus monkey
then you have tuned in to the right
place you've tuned into the winner's pov
hello welcome um connor's this is
conor's chance for his redemption arc
uh because i believe that he's never
beaten me in a tournament setting um
i don't think he's got in a single game
with me in the
in tournament one so let's see
if he's able to get his first dub um we
haven't played too much
off stream we played uh we did play a
few games
on stream like a few weeks ago and that
turned out all right
are you the fated rivals honestly like
this is this is more like an exhibition
game for us because there is a
there is a losers bracket this time and
i know whoever loses
uh we're going to expect the other
person to get to the finals
that's that's how i feel anyway if i
lose then you
bet you're asked that i'm going to meet
conor in the finals if connor loses then
i'm going to want to meet him in the
finals honestly
um all right looks like they're gonna
have a interview right now
did he just call you grunt i don't think
so i don't think so i don't
i don't think you made that mistake i
hope not
trash taste trash talking before the
game honestly like
he's called choke dog for a reason right
name
namely one time conor hasn't choked you
can't
because he always jokes
it's okay it's okay i'll play the
antagonist i'll play the antagonist for
season two i'm too
i'm the one who's too overpowered now
i've i've lost my plot armor
my fourth armor is gone if conor doesn't
get the plot armor this time
then he's just going to be the ash
ketchum
of trash taste forever
real friends call it as it is respect
oh connor's watching me i hope you're
listening to this connor
here return villain i do get of course
of course we we need character arcs here
you know maybe maybe conor will get that
verified buff because he's finally
verified on twitter now
so he's no longer a peasant so maybe
maybe now that he's joined the table of
the kings he'll finally get to that buff
that he needs
gonna get this gonna gonna get this w
for the crustless gang of course i am of
course i am
pre-planned corner choke for crash trash
taste content it's funny
when connor's on his own channel he uh
he's the one that ends up winning but
when it's on trash days i don't know for
some reason
he always ends up losing or not winning
aside from the pc build stream but he
almost he almost threw that
let me see uh
[Music]
yes i am ready to
start
the
to start
yeah it's fine i'll i'll take the easy
dub today it's not apex
it's a it's it's a it's a thinking game
we don't go monkey mode here this is a
gentleman's game
kind of talking trash about your drug
drinking habits honestly i just don't
have a glass of me right now
i uh i have my coffee
oh great has john has connor's chat
invaded
are you youtuber yes i am youtuber
watch connor watch you alright let me
let me check out connor's channel let's
see what's going on
look at this guy look at this guy i
think my chat is invaded
all right guys we're here with the
players techtone and rustage
uh wow that that was that was amazing
techy i actually i want to start with
you first by saying like
you played some seriously strong chess
despite
the results really good i tried
i really tried but um jt knows this i
have no idea how to checkmate
like i'm trying really hard but like
when rustage was like coming at me with
all that [__] i was like what
like i was like 13 i was up 13
and i still had no idea like when russia
just because i know that you
because i know that you don't know techy
and they'll probably get through it but
i'm just gonna jump the gun
you know when i move my queen that you
took yeah it was a misclick it was it
wasn't a
misplay i accidentally let go of my
mouse and miss click that queen
you'll love to hear it you really like
that i literally had like a
traumatic experience happen i started
actually crying
i i was like so distraught by the fact i
missed my queen
yeah i was just i was sitting there and
i was like hmm
i'm up 13 pieces but all of these pawns
are holding in every piece that i want
to use
and i have no idea how to free them up
because even though you were behind by
so much
like you were still super aggressive and
like i was just
i noticed that you had an open king side
and i had rooks on that open king side i
knew that
and you had your queen all up in the
business and i knew that yeah as long as
i kept pressuring on the queen i could
slowly start moving my pieces to attack
the king's side
i was i wasn't actually trying to win
that game i was trying to draw
and or clock you out because i knew i
couldn't win
there was a bit at the end where i
thought you were going to move your
king down and then i would move my rook
and then you'd move and you'd move back
and forth because i wasn't sure if you
knew about
repetition stalemates because i was i
was going to try and repetition
stalemate you
because like no yeah yeah i think i
think garn got a win over
conor in the first tournament arc by
doing that very same thing so i think
i'm aware of that
i think so okay okay yeah yeah but dude
you played some awesome chess like i
can't even be mad
i i was trying my hardest but like
literally hey
you were the better man it wasn't even
i think you're great you did amazing um
i think i had a little
i was looking at some of your games i
don't know if you looked at any of my
games
no um so i i i was looking to some of
your games and noticed you
started playing the same opening to um
every single you started doing this new
opening right which was
it was a pretty cool unusual opening but
i i
spent my instead of like playing games
and stuff i spent my time trying to
devise a counter strategy to that
specific opening
dude that's what that's what i thought
would i thought that would happen but
like uh yeah
i did not look at your games at all i
don't know i mean if you looked at my
games you would have just seen i just
played the london
okay no that's super smart i mean like
if i
had if i yeah i mean i that's that's
pretty much like my bread and butter
and i haven't been playing chess for too
long so i just tried to learn one shot
really good but
that's pretty smart it's underneath what
your opponent is playing and then just
kind of i think it would if i didn't
take a look at your games and started
planning for it i think it would have
thrown me off
so hard i would have been like what the
[__] is he doing and i would have
panicked i mean i hope nobody else looks
at him
nobody else is watching these games
hippo life
it's like naturally not a gamer i'm very
good at and you seem to you seem to have
picked it up very well
and you're you're incredibly smart at it
and seeing how you like your evaluator
is is is great because
like even though i didn't play chess at
all since last year
i did participate last year and stuff so
i
you know i have had a little bit more
experience than you but honestly when we
went into this match i thought we were
like
equal matched right which is why i was
stressing out about it like if i was
playing against connor
i'm i wouldn't stress because like oh
he's obviously we're better than me
whatever but i knew it could have gone
either way
yeah my uh my [__] out all this week was
like your rust is just going to eat you
alive techy really
yeah we're like there is no way you're
gonna [__]
die all right
i'm not like i yeah also for the record
running on like
no sleep i woke up at 6 a.m this morning
and it's one am right now
i wasn't able to like come on man you
beat me dude you can't tell me you beat
me on no sleep too bro
i was like dignity you almost caught me
out in your first game
[Music]
you almost timed me out in the first
game i was really worried i had like 20
seconds remaining
that was the plan i was like i don't
know how to beat this someone just
running
for the best no honestly i i honestly
think
like i just got really lucky in that
game and
my move that checkmated you i didn't
think would be a checkmate i was just
trying to just keep checking you
you played really good chess not like
that's the end but you were the better
man i 100 percent agree
i think you you play incredibly you were
really good and it's an honor to play
against you you were great
i appreciate the same to you yeah and i
think you guys definitely
we believe you guys played unbelievable
chess and
i apologize i realized that me and techy
were just talking i don't know you guys
yeah i was about to ask like do you want
you want us to go get you anything
or like
i think techy's just really like a
naturally charismatic personality
i think i think this conversations i
think this just tells us that we need
a collab because techy came out with
some music recently
said he was starting a rap career like
dude
well it was a meme to be honest i might
but uh these old pipes are retired
yo jt out of curiosity did i make you
proud
yeah yes yes you made me extremely proud
you did really well
there were so many moves that you did
that i had well i took two minutes with
one move
because you made a move i was like what
the [__] am i supposed to do here i
remember that i was stoked i was like
yeah bro
let that clock run oh yo if you go back
and you watch
uh my perspective when when i get that
queen i
straight up a leap out of my chair i'm
like dancing in the back of the room
because it was such a good move
no because i got a free queen and i was
so happy oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah honestly you know
what i'm glad i could give you that bit
of happiness
even i still got one moment of happiness
i i don't know which perspective
they put on stream you celebrating or me
crying during that moment
but you'll have to watch the team both
at the same time
just like you jumping around well i'm
like distraught
i have a feeling it might be out on the
internet somewhere i'm not sure but let
me ask you guys before we let you go
of course uh before i let you guys go
now we know who your opponents are going
to be
in the follow-up day i believe thursday
russ is just going to be playing against
crazy ollie
and techtone you're going to be playing
against kizzy let me ask you first
rustage
how do you feel about that matchup you
and ollie
well ollie's great uh she
i actually managed to have a
conversation with her earlier this week
um and he's definitely very determined
enthusiastic i think it'll be
very fun beforehand um she was
when we were talking she thought she was
going to lose i thought i was going to
lose and i was like oh but it's fine
we'll just play each other in the losers
bracket
at least it's a win-win then but now but
then when she won i was like oh [__] now
it's not a win-win anymore
and techie what do you think about your
match against kizzy how do you feel
going into that next
i'm stoked i'm absolutely stoked uh
i i did watch the little bit of oz or
ollie versus kizzy's game
uh it looked like a damn good uh you
know
um match and i i feel like the hippo
strat will have
a a good chance at thriving in that
matchup
hopefully unless that's what i call it
so
yeah i feel like i'll have a favorable
match-up and uh i'm gonna try to play my
best chest that i can as possible so i'm
stoked
i have one final question for you guys
um
i'll take views for extra stage now
playing in this first round match
what is your game plan for the next
matches that you're going to play
i'll just do the same thing i guess that
i did against techy
i'll look at olly's games and see how
she plays
[Music]
like a thief in the night ready to
backstab me when i go through that
allergies
i gotta do my research it's all i
[__] have if i
i gotta make a plan if i'm not prepared
i'm gonna fumble
because i take so long to think there
was so many moves where i'm like if i do
this and he does that then he does this
and it does that and it does this and if
i
roughly know what i'm doing i could be a
little bit more confident in myself so
that's what i'll probably do
is see what sort of openings and stuff
ollie plays and trying to
do that and techie what about you what's
your preppy yeah
so i feel like um like a martial artist
repping from the uh you know like dragon
ball z you had like
the the the hermit crew like the master
roses
taught goku and krillin i feel like i'm
like krillin in this scenario and jt's
master yoshi
and i'm gonna try to wrap our fighting
style which is the hippo strat and bring
a w home for the hippo boys and chat
hippo how i was gonna say more like i
was gonna say more like you need to be
piccolo
and jt can be commie and you guys can
merge and become like the ultimate
i feel like that violates something i
play policy please
all right guys well we gotta reference
there
all right well we gotta let you guys go
thank you so much for this amazing first
round and uh
we'll see you both again on thursday
sounds good thanks for having me
thanks thank you so much good game guys
and there you go that was the boys and
they're moving on
what an interview what an interview jt i
don't know
what we got to do here other than get
our next match prepped which is going to
be
sea dog va versus gig this
right here is almost a year
in the making people sin since sea dog
was defeated
and and he was like the clear favorite
in that match mind you
defeated in the most anime way possible
it's time guys we're here jt
are you ready for sea dog vs giggit
2.0
i'm honestly not this is this is so
exciting because what if
it's sea dogs time to shine because look
at this there's so many situations that
can happen right
speedo can win guard loses
and then he loses again in the
redemption arc and then it falls off and
then sea dog can either
lose the touring arc right that's the
sea dogs to lose or win right
let's say another scenario sea dog wins
art loses
but then comes back to the grand finals
and faces corner again what if
and then guard wins again oh that's
going to be too high now what if
what wins sea dog has to do the
redemption arc
it comes back and wins
there's so many possibilities i don't
know why we chose this bracket like this
is so
one of the plot armor is too thick i
know why we chose this
first round i know why we chose this
is because we want to give the people
what they want
right away and and who knows maybe conor
does lose the first match and then he's
like dio he keeps coming back
he keeps coming back we're about to find
out guys stay tuned because when we come
back game one
sea dog v rustage 2.0 who's got the plot
armor who's the villain who's the
protagonist we're about to find out
see you in a sec what they want
right away and and who knows maybe
connor does lose
our text finished streaming you're not
going to watch he's coming back he keeps
coming back
we're about to find out guys stay tuned
because when we come back oh technically
you think of the rainbow dude
sea dog v rustage 2.0 who's got the plot
armor who's the villain who's the
protagonist we're about to find out
see you in a sec jesus all right
oh they put the camera on me you know
i'm not [__] myself i just call i
shouldn't say that on the chess.com
stream
i no longer have a bad case of food
poisoning
um not that nervous you know this should
be easy to uh
dispatch can't hear just annihilate him
you know it shouldn't be too difficult
um so we're just gonna do it shoot
business as usual today
taking out the trash you know gonna get
in my witness bracket
get to the the grand finals and when
that's the plan for today
famous last words well you know i feel
like you gotta have a winner's mindset
to even stand a chance so if we have to
trash talk a little bit to get in the
zone that's fine
that's fine there's an ad running right
now
yo what's up ad block users we got this
boys we're going to win this one
i feel the dub comment i feel a dab
coming two dubs coming
i feel it i feel it we're gonna we're
gonna win this voice
i'm gonna win this this chat is one fps
adblock doesn't work on twitch i don't
know why i don't get ads on twitch
i'd never get ads i don't know why
uh joey said check his latest tweet
oh i can't check right now
this is gonna be an easy task i should
get the chess.com board ready you've
been logged off for inactivity well that
that sucks isn't it
yeah hopefully they tell us when we're
starting this
all right boys 10k we've got 10k viewers
bro 10k viewers about to see me redeem
myself
don't jinx it uh wait i see my blood
it's writing what's what's wrong
i'm reading for rapid my blitz is wait
wait what what what rating was that
oh it's my bullet rating oh yeah my
bullet rating i suck a bullet
15 minutes oh so we're not playing for
15 minutes damn
so we actually don't start until the
time off
hey i just met you all right this is
crazy
they don't think the ten bucks remind i
can't say that
remind you it's bad sportsmanship
i'll i'm gonna win i'm gonna win fair
and square no mind games here i'm just
gonna be the better player today that's
all there is to it you know
god's higher rating than me but you know
god plays in the comfort of his home i'm
used to being a clown on stream you know
i'm fine this is
nothing new to me um
repeat physical condition today
should be good should be good nothing to
worry about here nothing to worry about
ollie just said if connor loses she
won't play apex for a month
i can't have that no no ollie you can
you can still play apex
you can still play apex holly
i think it's okay you can still play it
the charge rifle will be lonely
nothing you nothing you can break during
this tournament so it's def a dub
bro we'll win we'll win i'm sure of it
i'm sure of it today
guys don't lose faith you know if we
have a little shaky start we may lose
the first game don't worry we'll come
back we always do
we
muted i got muted
i got muted
jojo music maybe maybe towards the end
game
i'll get a selection it's copyright
though
all right is your mic the tlm-103 it
sure is
just stretching just stretching just
chilling out having a good time you know
just waiting for the game
um yeah
uh oh my god i forgot that doesn't mute
me to the stream that means we just
should have done the that what
oh it doesn't work if i close my mouth
right i think the winner will be
hey
all right we actually asked the players
if they'd be willing to
uh start a little bit early because it's
18 p.m pacific time and why wait right
if they're both ready let's just
freaking do it
so obviously we have to choose who gets
to play with the white pieces first
so jt here we go how about you because i
see it
who's it going to be just take a guess i
think it's going to be
sea dog sea dog okay let's spin watch it
be current
hey look at you you got it okay c-dog
gets the white pieces nice
very nice very nice and then obviously
prediction easy clap
all right so whoever uh wins this match
is going to move up and face esam
uh tomorrow actually and then whoever
loses
will face sagam in the redemption arc
side of the bracket
i think really honestly
for me both outcomes are going to lead
to exciting matches
e sam very very strong player say jam
also strong for somebody who's only been
practicing chess for a week
he he's had a great fight against esam
yesterday and um
and now we are going to see
this thing go down um between
sea dog and gigguk i'm
setting the stage here we go i mean
they're underway
they're ready they're they're at it
it is time and after you know
e4 here
e4 and then c5 cecelia knight c3 knight
c6 and these moves are being
blitzed out
i like it i like it
i wonder which sicilian part is going to
go for
there are a lot of lines here i wonder
which one he studied
and going for a classical with the
knight to f6 and then playing a close
sicilian
saying hey i don't really want to do
anything and just playing d3 develop
getting the pieces out yeah
i should know more about my openings and
the open variation would be when they
played
d4 but not now but in a little bit when
this usually this knight is
on f3 and breaking in the center and i
think this is a little bit too early i
think they're moving a little bit too
fast
let's pressure him early
giggling he wants to pressure him early
ah i [__] this up haven't i uh uh
ah i haven't
yes i have oh i [__] up ah
i've blundered
[__] all right
it's last time i do a opening where i'm
not familiar with
with it holy [__] i just blundered early
hmm it's like a it's okay
hmm okay let's just uh let's get back in
this game
you just admit that he's playing an
opening he's not familiar with
yeah i i thought he was going for
sicilian i i thought he might have seen
a few videos on it maybe some openings
on chess.com
um and some of the lessons there but
i guess he didn't i'm now playing g6
makes me wonder if he sees
if he saw my videos on some dragon stuff
but maybe we have
an idea there's there is one idea here
that might save the piece if we play
bishop here
and then take the knight because then
the bishop would be free
this there might be a way to save this
let's
let's see what uh connor has in store
for us
i feel like he's not gonna do that he's
gonna want bishop here
i'm gonna develop the knight i think
that's best right now
he's probably doing a castle right
kind of wanted to do this though block
his bishop india i'm gonna queen
this is good we got the uh we can take
this next turn if he doesn't do
something
he has to block this or maybe i'll just
miss it
nice good stuff
dog in very good form
yep don't be expected
blocking with the bishop in order to
allow
the queen to defend the rook that is now
being eyed by the queen so what's next
for sea dog jt
how do you keep the momentum going as
white
uh well here i mean we just have to
bring the queen back most likely
and just develop our pieces
we are up in material so no need to rush
anything
and develop our night and
just take it from there just play chess
play solidly solidly
get our pieces out and we should have a
good game and an easy game because
we're also up upon a huge fawn too
now conversely what would your advice be
for giggit now
down material and on the defensive
down material i think we just need to
hold on to our pieces maybe we try to
trade some pawns don't be too hasty to
trade
try to get your pieces to good places
and try to
outmaneuver your opponent
and we'll see what kind of maneuvering
gigguk is considering i like that he's
got arrows out so we can also kind of
see inside his brain
can he do anything no let's just play
safe
my only hope right now is i develop
faster than he does
um yeah i can't really do anything
it feels bad man feels bad i really
can't come up with a game plan
i'm on the defensive right now uh
that's
what's the best game plan and it's still
anybody's game remember
one mistake can bring garth back into
this game
so true
to make this a flawless victory
no immediate danger of a checkmate but
it's on the horizon
i feel
yeah i i honestly feel like this is
going to get kind of dangerous and if if
white can find some like really nice
plans obviously we're already up pieces
right
but if we can find some ideas like maybe
like some h4 and try to get this truck
open over here
the you know the queen and bishop
battery the the standard stuff right
and that would be really really awesome
but king safety as well i mean seadox
king's in the middle of the board and if
you lose momentum
then that could come back to bite you
right
true true um i i still want
everybody to develop the pieces i think
aren't it's probably gonna go for
maybe like a bishop c6
idea and try to get everything active in
this position and maybe the rook can
come to b8 attack this pawn
make this bishop a little bit stronger
we we might have a lot of ideas here so
aren't not out of it just yet
there's still a lot of play in the
position left yeah and i think
conor is the kind of player who is also
examining gigguk's ideas
as well as his own and that might be why
he's spending a lot of his time here
let's
take a listen threatens this okay um
think i should just castle
unfortunately it's a boring move but i
think it's the right move
[Music]
yeah we expected this
like a true jojo fan conor expects
every move
and here um let's see if they're going
to if the bishop is going to take the
knight and it does not ideal
it's fine
[Music]
he's gonna start trying to attack me i
might move this bishop here
hmm this is uh
yeah he might go here in which case
i do one up right
but then there's no pawn that can
challenge this one except that this
one's blocked
and he has to move which will probably
just take that i think i'm probably
trying to double up my pawns again
i love that he's taking his time here
oh i did not expect that i did
does that make me a good player jt that
i expected queen e5
um yes
it's called job security
[Laughter]
um but yeah queen e5 i think the same
move works it was
in its calculation but now this bishop
seems a little bit
awkward and we might
be able to pressure
maybe with some some nice moves like
here maybe a little check at some point
so it might get kind of dicey here so
aren't garnet has a really good game
ahead of him and sea dog is
not in the clear just just yet yeah and
how do you feel about maybe
planting your bishop on d4
and have that sort of like
indestructible feeling
bishop pawn combo they defend each other
they're holding a lot of center-ness and
they're eyeing f2
and like what do you think am i two for
two
terms yeah yeah yeah yeah
the technical term centre-ness
i've been doing a lot of meditation so
centerness is just it's
it's in everything now
always trying to stay centered i um and
i honestly think that
here we might have to defend this pawn
because if the bishop comes here
this pawn is going to be attacked twice
right
but there might be an opportunity that
if the bishop does
move here and let's say they don't find
like a move like f3
then there might be a stalemate
opportunity here or not
a repetition here don't you dare and
don't you dare you no
it can't work it can't work it can't
work you're lucky
i was like
although i don't know who that's more
traumatic for between the two of them
uh let's let's listen and see what's
going on right now
hmm what are you trying to do
let's take that first
let's go there
let's put some pressure on his king
our minds are merging our minds are one
it's probably gonna go there
i can go there
i'm just super excited to see what
happens like let's say they play
like c3 with uh orange envisioning
bishop g7
and if knight takes on c5 we have that
uh
perpetual idea the perpetual check
idea so let's say you know bishop g7
and if knight takes then we have okay
well
the check first is good
interesting i wonder right at this
moment
if sea dog like i just want to know
what's going on here sea dog
being attacked like this in the first
game
i don't know what to expect here i mean
this is this is too
much he's probably not thinking he was
gonna be here in game one
you could check him by going back once
he won a piece
oh i'm gonna do something greedy i'm not
gonna i'm gonna go here
because i want this fork
don't know if he sees it
please move something else move your
bishop yeah he might move his bishop
did my check me i'm playing so risky
here
my heart is racing i really wanted to
miss this fork
i wanted to move his bishop somewhere i
can just offer a trade or something
it's gotta be hard seeing all those not
like this emotes in the chat and
wondering what it means
when you know the funny thing is is that
this is what races through people's
heads
all the time in chess tournaments like
my mind goes a million
miles an hour and sea dog is just
on the stream like hey this is exactly
what i'm thinking like i hope he's
misses this i hope he doesn't do this
and of course we have to plan for the
best situation right
we can't play hope chess and what hope
chess does is when you're
you hope your opponent plays a move that
you just win immediately
sometimes i'm just like please please
please please but i obviously have to
plan for the best move
i can't play risky all right
i can't afford to um but here i think
a simple queen f3 which was found on the
board queen of three
very very strong saying well you know
you have to go back
right but i mean if you're gigging do
you really want to just settle for a
draw in game one like this
i feel like he's gonna press
i mean you're down a piece
you're down to pizza i would i would
take a draw down a piece and i don't see
any mating attack
true so let's let's see what i'm
thinking
yeah uh wow it's gonna do to him again
don't i i gotta
all right i'll get i'll get him next
game i'll get him okay he's settling for
it
i'll get him next game i've landed i
[__] blundered
um so i'll get him next game
i've got to get him next game no maybe
this is happening
all right
i [__] blundered that piece i've
gotta go for the next game
wow he said it dude he's like you know
what all right
my hands up i i wonder how it has to
feel if you're a sea dog
to see that draw by repetition pop up
again
and be like
yes probably some kind of like
i think i like ptsd from like just
the whole the one game he drew and that
cost him the whole tournament
and got second place oh man i wonder how
sea dog is feeling here
all right well we'll find out during the
break as we get ready for game two gig
with the white pieces saying he's just
gonna have to get him in the next one
and we'll find out if that's gonna
happen we'll be right back in just a
moment
because i think his um his queen was
trapped here right
i go there he needs to like do something
to help right
i don't know the screen's trapped here
right i know you can go there
i just you just do this right
moves the bishop away or some [__] i
don't know
oh well fair enough
it is what it is bit unfortunate that i
uh
forgot about that rule
making it exciting guys making it
exciting no worries
we'll get him on the next one we they
had us in the first half
i think i played better chess than gone
there wait what was the game report let
me look
oh god played better than me apparently
hmm
oh i should have done that uh
yeah that's my bad
this is so sad i was winning as well
[__] my life
well ah well that was
that was unfortunate hey we'll get over
the next one sorry
we played better than him there so
it's all through all of dance ideas
we'll be fine we'll be fine all right
which way for the next one i guess
[Music]
no worries we'll win on black no worries
at all
we got this gamers believe believe
god probably knows what i'm doing as
well but he knows what i'm going to go
for
he tries to mix it up though he tries
his best to throw me off in like every
way
i bet he'll do he won't do e4 or d4
he'll do some weird thing i bet
he only he always does this
[Music]
oh
just chilling now just chilling just
chilling
just waiting i wonder what god was
saying
i i won't know i won't check this one
i'm too lazy
all i know is that we're gonna be gone
it'll be simple
simple
just chilling just waiting waiting my
game to start
i was getting nervous towards the end
there i was like [__] i i i think i
shouldn't have draw that that should
have been my game that's a bit
unfortunate but
no way no way so we win again
i totally forgot i had uh i'd done that
move once more
i should have checked before i just
assumed
big sage although i know i
if we get gone on the sticky position
he's he's bad with his time management
so i know if we do that i did take way
too long just figuring out the castle as
well earlier as well actually i did do
that that's pretty bad for me
i can't do that again
all right 90 oh it's starting like 30
seconds i think
all right boys let's get this dub let's
get this dub
it will be but a simple task
[Music]
i don't know about simple connor uh but
what i do know is that all of us
me you jt we get two games
guaranteed because they drew that first
game and it is a best of three match
which means you can't win it until you
have at least two points
and if we get one win a piece
we get tie breaker 3o chess it's gonna
be crazy dude
can't ask for better a better moment
right not only did we get a draw
in the first game and then we got a lot
of craziness in the other rounds but in
this round we have a draw to start it
off
not even waiting until the last moment
to draw we got us draw
just right off the bat so if sea dog
wins
and then guard wins then we get the oh
man this is this is
good this is awesome well let's do it
the game is going to begin any moment
and gig now with the white pieces
he's got his turn to make the first move
and we are off
all right let's go
[Applause]
let's uh let's not [__] this up gant
don't [__]
[__] this up
uh okay
i'll do now very interesting opening
choice
from sea dog
little concerning that it's taking
giggix so long to make these first
opening moves
it it makes me think he's not really
prepared
for opening sea dog is going to play in
this movie oh i didn't mean to do that
but
there we go
ah sure let's trade
and the caro khan being one of the most
solid
defenses for black
so i think we're gonna see a positional
battle and
let's see who comes out on top and to
see a positional battle at this training
is like
rare but we know that these players are
stronger than their ratings
yeah they're both definitely capable of
working these positions
gigguk seems to me a little bit less
confident right now in these opening
moves but
remains to be seen right it's too early
to tell one way or the other
now what do you do about your knight on
g8 if you're black here right your queen
is sitting on
the the central-ish
what did i say before central-ish
centralness
centralness it's sitting on your
centralness now you maybe have to
develop it to h6
is that is that a thing i mean now your
bishop is on
f5 like where does that night go does it
just sit there
um for right now it can sit right there
but i think the life is going to be uh
e7
and then maybe to f5 um there is
some pressure here on these two pawns
because of this
d pawn potentially taking right so maybe
even
g6 might be an option in some of these
cases and
many times in the cairo khan this bishop
wants to be traded off if and then to
play c5 so we get a better french but
now with the
bishops turn it off i'm wondering
what the plan is for sea dog right now
um i i would assume just to keep
developing pieces
on good squares something like knight c6
and
maybe moving the queen somewhere maybe
to d7
or c7 later in the future to allow for
knight to e7
but let's peek in on c doc's stream and
see how he's trying to work this out
you know something i learned recently is
that if you want to focus
music without lyrics is the best way to
go
music oh you don't get distracted by it
hopefully he takes
somebody's talking to you that'd be
really nice
yeah i figured you'd be doing something
like this so whenever a good beat drops
or instrumental drops
i used to do poetry in high school and
so i always just want to rap on the beat
so for me that i think it's more
distracting
music with no lyrics because then i
don't hear something if i if i hear a
beat then i'm like
yeah i'm getting on that you want to put
something in there
right right right oh so maybe what
that's what it's like for our man rested
she can't listen to instrumentals
we'll have to find him right right um
let's see it's a tight spot now
and cleaning boys is very annoying
is super super annoying here
um well what to do i mean i feel like
the only move here is to play
queen to c7 right queen to c7 is
maybe the only movie because the idea is
even if they take this pawn this phone
is going to be for every week right
these two pawns are going to be
extremely
weak
right and then maybe we can play along
the b file right like if our king is
able to castle
we can play along this b file so it
might not be the worst
idea in the world even down and i'm
going to use down
um temporarily
oh no
oh no what's going to happen here i i
want to listen into
garnet's uh
video because it's good i think it's
gonna about to get crazy
that's a free rook right
[__] up [__] sake i just realized
what i did oh my god i wasn't looking
[__] sake
ah that's okay though i think we can we
can do this
oh i [__] up i [__] up
that's bad no i can't if i didn't spot
that i would have
always spotted that normally
it might be the pressure all right now i
castle
let's get my king out of that
it might be the plot armor kick
i got some free stuff now let me get
safe okay cool right now i can't do the
[__] annoying move anymore
this is one sad night this is one sad
night
and this is one sad rook because then i
can't move anywhere
oh wait you can move there that's no
it's not a great square for the night
actually it might be
hmm i can't if i messed this up god damn
it i wasn't paying attention i was too
worried about the pawn i didn't think
about what happens when you take the
pawn
on an amateur mistake
amateur mistake
rookie rookie
yeah i knew he'd do that okay jojo
so here's the thing all right so
you can you can maybe if your giga
leave your queen camped out because
now conor
can't develop that knight because it
drops the rook
right and we talked this
we talked about this in the old
tournament are the first tournament arc
where i showed a game between
gary kasparov and zapalov and basically
to bore you with
my new details but the overall concept
was there are pieces making other pieces
bad and you need to solve that
and right now sea dog needs to solve it
all of his pieces are basically bad he
has three pawns
or four pawns on the king side but he
needs to solve the issue of the night
being bad and the rook being bad
um i hope that he can find a solution
yeah and actually i just realized
conversely the rook can't move either
because there's nothing defending the
knight
wow what a bind
what a bind and giga also looking at
some slow roll moves here as well
i need to protect
um all right so here here
maybe you may be maybe here first than
here
and then that's a very annoying night
it's a useless night i need to i need to
get my other pieces into the game
um
see what can you possibly do
i love the way he's thinking here
not even caring for the pawn on
a6 right not even caring at all saying
hey my queen
is way better i'll just stop taking
people because it's something tonight
and
commentators curse jj
[Laughter]
no
but that said it is fine everything is
fine so far
good good is doing good on time and
on the board and yeah he's uh
connor's got to go to problem solving
mode yeah she's trading now he's trying
to get the dub
i gotta get my knight involved now
luckily his knight can't really do
anything
uh
okay that would have been a good
question
this is super interesting yeah he finds
its way that i was
i was getting like 97 myself so good
yeah
recognition i i was uh thinking about
maybe
putting my knight here so instead of
playing to f6
like maybe e7 and then f6
speaker you have the f6 move to kick out
the knight
hmm well okay i mean conor is starting
to
work his way into the position here it's
it's not straightforward but
uh the knight moves with tempo against
the rook the rook's got to go
somewhere
okay and that's a solid move by giggs
right both of these pawns on the f-file
are in danger
i'm worried about a move like this and
just a little fork and
oh hey hey
hello commentator's curse uh but is
there isn't there
some this man now as i'm trying to find
a way to save both
rooks but there's no check
all right i mean now you're only down at
night yeah instead of being down a road
also a few pawns
narrowing the gap and let's see how good
it feels about that
not a problem small blunder there small
blunder
small blunder uh i don't know what that
was
we want to get this [__] night in the
game this night just been sitting here
this entire game
it's been so [__] lonely all right
time to go like
time is time to start pushing i got a
passport
talking about the night and then looking
at ponza set as like saying man i really
do need to do the laundry
but i'm not
okay there you all right all right now
my knight's in the game
he kept making all these moves extremely
quickly
oh and we got a runner about this yeah
this is great for giggup right because
now conor has to think about
this weakness at the wing
it's gonna pull him away from other
[Music]
concerns
wow and look at that centralized night
yeah very interesting here i'm wondering
what happens if
i would not trade that oh i would not
tweet that but
i mean we're going for it yeah i mean
maybe conor thinks that trading that
night helps him get to those runners but
i'll just
operate on the other side of the board
right it'd be a huge blunder if he moved
to this there's a saying that
ass pawns must be pushed so [__]
blundering
there you go two weaknesses
[Music]
what are you thinking you just you need
to keep pushing it
i can't reach it
oh no
sag maybe he'll blunder it
maybe the ultimate hope chest may be
the blundering maybe
pigs will fly
right but what happens if
this is wholesaling i hate this [__]
endgame [__]
i hate it so much
let's see
i'm just being annoyed now um checks are
good we like checks
check all the way to the finish line
they say that you should always check
because it might be me
they say i'm a dreamer but i'm not
chad knows what's up okay here we go
here we go
let's let's see if he can finish it off
okay does he remember
how to keep this simple and clean
he said that yes
let's make this a clean game
okay
okay seems pretty uh last movie last
move
all right bring the king yep yeah okay i
i
he's got this they're correct yep
very nice and that's it cleanly done now
this is where you resign
[Music]
all right clean win let's go wow
no blunders today no [__] blunders
today wow
holy [__] zero mistakes zero blunders
zero miss wins
that's what i like to see i believe it i
believe it that was clean
he was not wrong that was a clean win
so how about here now it's sea dog's
turn to win he has to win this
yes and what happens if he wins
we go to the breakout and then we have
the death deafness and now
that is a draw again yep and they just
keep drawing and we're here
all night i would be down for it guys uh
but we have to take a break before we
get to that game so
see you in a moment i'll leave you with
c dog uh to explain
how he's gonna approach this last game
we'll be right back
[Music]
damn my accuracy was so high that game
it was literally that one mistake that
one mistake cost me
i just didn't want to give up this
position
[Music]
oh first the two points wins oh oh [__]
we got another game
pog there's a chance
i think i'm not gonna lie i think i
played better than gone
but i made that one mistake so i guess
they didn't but god didn't make any
mistakes either i think
[Music]
i had the right ideas with all my moves
but yeah i messed up that one really
important move there which
is a bit unfortunate
[Music]
yeah let's see move sucked this one
this is what lost me it's really sad
i the reason why i didn't do it in my
head is that i thought i'm gonna lose
this anyway i don't know why i thought
that
i really didn't want to give up um this
because uh in my head i was like oh okay
well if i go here
fix this right and then i don't know
what to do from this position
bring nine out maybe yeah i guess so
i'll just think of the castle off then i
wouldn't be a bad spot i just lost one
pawn
and i'm threatening this right
[Music]
yeah obviously when my queen can move
but it's still there but
yeah okay that's not too bad actually i
don't feel too bad about that game
bit unfortunate but it'd be like that no
worries gamers no worries don't fear not
guys don't worry we'll get them in the
next one we'll get them in the next one
i'm confident i'm confident i'm very
confident
if god makes a mistake i will capitalize
on
same way that god did for me
no apex planned collab exception in
august if connor loses
[__] i can't do that ollie don't do it
like that
i don't want to let ollie down that's
that's what i'm really worried about i
don't want to let ollie down [__]
i can't let ollie down ollie this is for
you
i said they won't be long all right
we're waiting on it
we're gonna get the next dub it's
unfortunate we got the draw there i
yeah i [__] up oh this should be a dub
right now this should have been a dub
it's unfortunate but uh oh well
when i play my chess i i know i can win
i'm just gonna [__] up
not [__] up like that and we get it we
get it
all right that's good
that's good let's get it let's get it
forever waiting that's
i want to see sadness in the chat guys
it's not over yet
and if it goes to three minutes i'm near
certain i can beat gone
god sucks at three minutes yes
so if we win this one we have a very
good chance
and i think we we played we've been
playing very well uh we obviously made
we made two dumb errors that and
it's unfortunate those two damn errors
actually cost us both games um
me forgetting about the draw rule and
gone i knew about the draw
rule but i thought i had one more turn
so that was my bad um
yeah and uh this one i just made one
mistake that cost me it's quite
unfortunate really
i guess i love my lesson because also
here i should have got um
yeah i should have castled before trying
this
i just i didn't need to push this away
i'm ready i'm ready all right good thing
that you're ready conor because
uh hey if you don't win there is
always apex am i right jt
yeah um let me know if they need a third
i i mean bloodhounds
yo guys it's time you know what
you know super funny um i only heard one
line in apex from
in japanese and it's a bloodhound line
are we are we down to view their game
because i'm i'm super stoked
yeah it's time they just started super
stoked here we go
all right let's go let's go and maybe
while we listen in
on gig you can give me a japanese lesson
what do you say
that sounds good that sounds good he's
obviously prepared
let's see this is super solid
super super solid i i'm enjoying this
kind of chess
uh does c dog keep playing these
structures you get the bishop
out i'm going to close your pawn chain i
am winning this time it seems like
this is actually winning this is
actually winning right this is
oh it's not winning this is actually i
don't lose this
i just i i like having an open center so
this time this time it's okay
i think it's because i played this
opening so many times that i [__] up
the previous one because i played an
opening
i played a different opening and i'm
just like this this pawns
this pawns fine is he right about that
jt
he's good he's fair he has the early
break
d5 knight this is super standard and
right here
uh usually castles is a pretty good move
uh another good move here is knight b to
d2 yeah he finds tassels
and then very simple plans for white
here is just to
play uh in some lines just rookie one
right away
and put a lot of pressure on this pawn
okay
see dog v8 is jamming to something let's
find out what that is
classic
[Music]
oh
we're playing chess today
oh it's good that he knows what game
he's playing
but
there is a huge tactic
that i hope he sees we actually covered
something like this here um
and wow like just this move here knight
captures e5
opportunity right now it seems like
you're giving away the queen
but then after this everything's
exploded because the
discover check and you're back to clean
plus some material
yes as soon as you clear the knight from
e5 it comes with a check because the
rook is staring the king down
whoa oh man
let's look at a sea dog's perspective
because i'm wondering what he's thinking
right now
i'm honestly wondering if he sees it
[Music]
okay doesn't necessarily change the
situation quite yet
[Music]
oh
i'm digging it i'm digging it
looking good looking good so far
there's a one hour version maybe i
should do the hour version
we should do that
[Music]
the same tactic is still available
not as strong but still available in
this position
[Music]
i feel like it's just too hard to spot
maybe
that's that's a that's a deep sequence
to get where you're going
you know it's tricky
it is very tricky i mean th
this this could be honestly this could
be the turning point because d4
has a very similar area saying hey i
want to target this e5 pawn especially
since my rook is here
on the e1 or on the e file right so
d4 with the same logic saying hey i
want to target that those weak pieces
right and the punch in the center cannot
take because you would be checking
yourself
so and also the knight can't take
because the bishop pins the knight to
the king wow this is actually
wow there's a lot that white is doing to
the position right now
well here we have another sequence here
uh we still have this again
the the knight captures e5 idea is still
available
to us like capture z5 is still available
to us
but uh right now we have this c4 idea
all right c4 or we just take we can open
it up fair enough
okay now do you think he takes back with
the rook or the knight here
here after f takes um i mean white's got
two options right
right right right now taking with the
brook wins the bishop doesn't it
i think you have the castle here and um
yeah yeah gig finds a way out of this
and at least that gives my rook space
yeah resourceful
because then that
is a real threat
yeah if he takes that she helps me gig
is like not so fast
because i want to give my rook space
right all right
and then i could take
already quality moves by both players
here
trade off ray
trade offer eh trade off right connor
do i want to take the trade offer
yeah it's an important decision
i think that if conor is still jamming
to the same song
if he has a high ready for this game
yeah maybe that's the secret sauce
i mean if i listen to that music i feel
like i can do anything
[Music]
i got time i'm a thing
you ever do that jt you think i get
close to the screen
i will see more moves
oh it's a proven fact the closer you are
the more you see
yes and the more money your optometrist
makes
well everyone needs a job right
you have to trade khan take the trade
offer
take the trade officer what's the
problem
he felt for the mistake oh no he
he's losing a knife here he's losing the
whole game is this the comeback
i simply don't have the [__] to give
oh how the turntables
that's two office jokes in one stream jt
come on
hmm
um this is really difficult here
this is really really difficult i do i
hate this
it's a danger of a checkmate
i've got to be careful of the checkmate
oh this this is going to be crazy
did you know that the word chest
literally translates to
careful of the checkmate
no i've never heard that a day in my
life
[Laughter]
you did now you did now he does have to
be careful of the checkmate it's the
name of the game
metaphorically right and so just to
translate what he said
tai han means like difficult um
so like he's in a difficult situation so
him bringing up the japanese it doesn't
mean he's in a precarious situation
oh this is uh this is
moto precarious look at this wait
oh wait can we can we go to sea dogs
yeah i think
he might see it here is does he have it
i think that's mate
[Music]
oh it's too easy it's too easy
it's too easy
we're like three blunders we're just
vibing over here bro
we've got tie breaks dude we've got tie
breaks
we got the tie breaks and i i said it
it's gonna be a draw
yes yes yes this isn't exactly what i
wanted guys
yes whoa let's
freaking go guys the chat is going
absolutely wild
we have tie breaks between
giga can see dog 2.0 oh my gosh this is
yo can you ask for better than this
that means apex is not off the table
that means that we have more matches
coming that means that we have more hype
and more
jojo music gonna happen so
oh i can't wait oh my gosh this is it uh
who do you want to look at i think i
think maybe we want to listen to gigguk
during the break here to see how he
feels about that
getting forced into a 3-0 where conor
said that he thinks
giga is at a major disadvantage in
faster chess so
we're gonna find out we'll let you guys
listen and we'll be back for tie breaks
three-minute chess see you in a sec
how do i disable comments
so
i'll have a look at the games after this
is over
uh
are we allowed to look at the previous
game i'm kind of just chilling now
kind of just trying to keep focused on
the game before it starts um
[__] man i just want to start i just
want to start the next [__] game
come on come on
i [__] hate blitz though i am not
looking forward to this one bit
i'll be i'm not gonna lie
i'm literally like i didn't want it to
come to three minute blitz
and i think connor has the advantage in
blitz
connor is pretty heavily advantaged
it's okay it's okay we can bring it back
go for the dub i believe i believe we go
for the dub
okay tie break in one minute i'm ready
i'm ready
i really didn't calculate enough in that
last game did it
all right and just to establish the
stakes here the winner of this match
will move on to the winner's bracket and
face esam
tomorrow at 6 30 p.m the loser of this
match
will then move into the redemption
bracket
play say jam and one of those two
players
tomorrow 5 pm will actually be knocked
out of the
tournament permanently so there are a
lot of things at stake here
besides just whether or not conor gets
revenge
for uh the tournament arc one so
jt as we get prepared to start i'm gonna
ask you
what is going to happen here
okay so there's the blitz portion right
now
and i'm gonna stick to my prediction if
he has golden wind
the background music that he was playing
still playing
during his game he will win it is the
tower
of the background music as much as i
like that take i actually have to say
i think the more focused player is going
to win this match so
we're going to find out right now the
game is going to begin we are off
and uh let's just put the players up and
let them uh commentate their own
tiebreaker here
winner moves on
okay theory every time john theory
proven
music exists
[Music]
child
a minute gecko's got his own music
i think chill music wins let's just play
the game
there okay maybe playing fast
real fast
[Music]
already looking at centralizing his
knight but maybe he drops the b2 pawn
[__] come on just gonna play just going
to play
each one is hang yep yep and connor
that is not cool
um
let's go there
you can take the one on c2 what's going
to do here
now maybe go there
gigger giving us the inside connor's
just jamming
slightly behind on time
i think he's in a better position than
me
both players two minutes a piece let's
keep pressuring us
aka one third of the game is over
i want to do that all sometime sometimes
wouldn't do that
there's only one move here
uh what do i want to do
your black pass again so here which one
do you want to take
good job okay job likes that what is
happening what is happening
can you find castles
wait you found it you found it okay but
what a game so far
[Music]
[__]
what do you say a little bit of cat jam
time
oh yeah oh man this is
so they're both they both have the same
amount of time
there's
[Music]
[__]
oh boy [__] i wasn't thinking
we need fast moves we need good moves
yep both players uh
oh god this is uh this is less than a
minute here oh right now
could this be over this is
it it's over it's over it's over
oh
holy [__] holy [__]
oh i made that one mistake that cost me
the game
choke dog v8 strikes again we'll get him
in the final again
don't worry about it connor you gave me
that
connor you gave me that oh
god i thought you're in a bad position
you gave me that
holy [__] come on
this was meant to be your redemption
arcona take it
take your redemption arc
wow wow the protagonist strikes again
gigguk uh denies
the revenge that conor has been talking
about getting for the last
year and now conor is gonna have to
fight his way
back in the redemption arc
to get another shot at kangook
wow wow what what a game they were both
playing extremely good chess
it was just literally one mistake that
changed the whole game
unbelievable
unbelievable i mean somebody had to win
it right we couldn't have just gone home
i i know we could have had draw after
draw but somebody was gonna move up
somebody was gonna move down and now we
have to ask them how they feel
about those prospects so we're gonna get
both players
in a call right now interview in just a
few moments
stay tuned
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
all right guys we're back we're here
with the boys and i'm gonna start with
connor what happened bro
you know um you know sometimes you know
you're playing
better and you just you just do one dumb
move and that's yeah that's kind of it
i felt like i was playing out of my mind
for most of that and i missed like
two moves here and there that cost me
that first game
absolutely no excuse that i lost that
that should have been an easy win
well it's it's it was yours to win and
you gave me the stalemate because i was
just like
should i go for the win and i'm just
like i thought i had one move
extra that i did for the stalemate so
that's what happened there
yeti yet another yet another match
between us that
gets decided because connor didn't
properly yeah because i would have won
if i got that with that game which i
easily would have
but uh yeah i mean i i thought we played
some pretty good games i thought
the third game was pretty even i thought
i was actually in a better position and
i haven't no
i felt like the third game i felt like i
was just destroying you left and right
like every move i thought like
i'm see every single move i'm like oh
this is easy i'm literally on autopilot
and the second game as well i thought
like oh i think i'm playing better than
you but i just have a worse position
and even i looked at the accuracy and i
have higher accuracy too better than me
and have the worst position
okay i literally made one bad move and
that was it that was the only thing i
did every other move i felt like i did
the best possible move but yeah i just
i did one bad move that was really bad
so that was it
yeah i mean i feel like uh i feel like
with the tie breaker it was actually it
was actually pretty damn close
uh i feel like you were in a slightly
better position than me and then
yeah i thought for some reason i've been
in this position before this is easy and
i miscalculated
and i lost i think i would have won that
as well i felt like i was in a better
position as well
yeah i thought you're in a better
position uh and then yeah you just kind
of
you could just kind of through um third
game i do want to look back on because i
feel like we were both in really
threatening positions
and i feel like you you put pressure on
me and i put pressure on you and then
i made some kind of error that just
opened the game up for you i i'll have
to look back um
second game i thought like i thought was
pretty damn [__] clean
um i i was like uh i i saw the
analytics and i had like zero blunders
zero mistakes zero missed wins
i'm just like that never [__] happens
that never happens i had yeah one
blunder that game but
and then nothing else because my
accuracy is higher than yours as well
i'm so sad about that
it's okay it's all good connor well all
i'll say now is uh
like we've got to do a rematch with this
in the final right that's that's
that's the only i'll win if i come back
i'll win well and the only logical
conclusion
and that's the question i think that
everybody uh wants to know
is sea dog are you gonna come back are
you gonna make your way all the way back
through cause that's a lot of matches
man
there's no other opponents i'm worried
about
[Laughter]
and maybe uh conversely gig how do you
feel about going up
against e sam tomorrow
honestly i saw esam's games uh yesterday
and he looks pretty solid
um i feel like um i feel like he wasn't
tested
to his full limit yesterday so i
it's on me to win it otherwise we can't
guarantee the grand final between me and
connor so i'm i'm hoping to win it and
all i can hope for is uh conor follow
kind of follows suit and here he wins
the remaining of his games as well yeah
yeah it'll be easy it'll be easy
i should watch i want to play more games
to practice so that's why i went to the
loser bracket so
that's uh i've played more games that's
natural yeah
okay that's optimistic jt what do you
got
other than lip syncing which is
hilarious sorry
when he makes it all the way through
sorry about that uh when he makes it all
the way through
uh giga who's going to win that match of
course it's still going to be me
like like until until like i don't know
why he's called himself chad dog v.a on
chess.com because until he wins an
actual tournament it still
should be choke dog for yeah that's what
he keeps doing that's what he keeps
doing
oh my god he got me in the heart there
you know i'll come back and then i'll
deserve the chad title when i win
honestly the uh the stage is set for
your redemption arc so
if you don't take him out this is on you
this is on you no i want to i didn't
want to beat you once
you know i feel like that would kind of
ruin the fun of beating you in the end
you know what i mean i feel like it
should be a an underdog story all the
way through so that's what i was trying
to set up today
all right all right yeah you're the
underdog today corner i'll give you that
but
underdogs have to take the victory when
they can take it
[Laughter]
like all i'm saying is i was the
underdog last time and now i've had
we've had the time skip park and i'm
like overpowered now
whereas conor's just at the same level
so you know it's like the goku vegeta
thing all over again i don't know i
i i'm pretty sure i made you sweat
pretty hard at those games god i
i'm pretty sure if i'd uh not been
stupid that would have been easy
well yeah yeah i i completely agree with
you connor if you had just not been
stupid
you probably could have won that but uh
that's yeah i was too busy trying to
pick a song for the first two matches
that's what kind of threw me off there
so that was kind of that was kind of
unfortunate
all right well maybe that was your final
yeah maybe that was your achilles heel
connor is uh you gotta change songs
yeah i gotta i think that's what i had
to do this is my bad yeah sorry
all right guys well that has been
fantastic obviously
everybody loved seeing you guys uh
playing in another match right off the
bat
and what's funny is that it is there's
actually two different paths where we
might see you guys
have another match uh sea dog could work
his way all the way
back up to the redemption arc but also
what's hilarious
and we didn't even think about is that
gigguk if you
don't win against esam i think you
end up in another match with conor right
away
yeah pretty much so pressures on me will
win tomorrow then i've gone on loose i'm
gonna be so annoyed because all the
he's kills all the hype you know what i
mean so the storyline will be ruined if
god loses so
i think i'm more nervous for that one
again as opposed to this
i think i'm more nervous with that match
than i was for this match against going
up
all right all right it's just corner
like you've got you've got to clean up
your game you can't let me be doing
those moves to you if you're gonna
you want to win it's like yeah so yeah
this one
this one was a warm-up game oh okay okay
we'll see
every protagonist needs to power up
through the tournament
they don't start off with that final
form they've got to like warm up right
like that like i literally blundered
within the first three moves of this
entire tournament and i don't
i think that's like the earliest blunder
anyone's made so far
from there it's only up from there all
right
i will see you both tomorrow good luck
you've got
just under 24 hours to do what you got
to do to get ready and uh
we'll see you guys then that was great
have a have a good rest of your night
and uh or day
as it were in japan and um and we'll see
you then
all right thank you so much for having
us everyone guys thanks guys
there you have it uh the bracket is set
winner side redemption side
uh who who believed it i i mean
chat what did you do is this what you
thought would happen today
jt you called it for connor dude you
said the music was gonna be power what
happened
he didn't change the music
he did not change it well he played the
one hour version instead of just a five
minute version changing it
he noticed his mistake and hopefully
he'll bring it back
yep maybe the mix up is the thing to do
so guys
uh what is tomorrow tomorrow is c jam
versus c-dog ba 5 p.m pacific
followed by e sam versus giggik at 6 30
pacific
so make sure that you uh write it down
on your calendar and be ready jt what an
amazing first round to the event and now
we move on to the bracket stage
uh any final advice that you may have
for
the players that might be uh watching
this broadcast right now before we go
take your time and i want you to look at
the games that the players have played
and see what they're playing
use it to your advantage there are a lot
of resources on chess.com that will help
you analyze and
make you confident in the openings and
maybe some middle game plays
you know who you're facing good luck
yep can't say it better than that good
luck to everybody and we will see all of
you back here tomorrow
at 5 p.m pacific for uh the next stage
of tournament arc 2. so
uh till then i'll say goodbye to
everybody and
uh and we'll go peace out y'all take
care guys
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
so
you